cryptocurrencies have been around for a
while now although first conceived in
the early 80s it would take until the
introduction of Bitcoin before it would
come to the forefront of just about
everyone smiled in this video we'll be
looking at how we think cryptocurrencies
would do 2020 along with what Bill Gates
Elon Musk John McAfee
van Buffet and some others think about
them Bitcoin released by the mysterious
autoshi Nakamoto would open the
Pandora's Box unleashing the magic of
cryptocurrencies on the world with its
sha-256 encryption and concepts of proof
of work it also led to the birth of
other cryptocurrency is called altcoins
some examples of all coins are like
current ripple it's helium and so on
cryptocurrencies are an internet-based
medium of exchange that uses
cryptography to ensure your transactions
are secure and that your assets are
transferred securely it also regulates
the number of cryptocurrency units
created former CEO Google Eric Schmidt
call them the remarkable cryptographic
achievement well Warren Buffet the CEO
of Berkshire Hathaway asked people to
stay away from it calling it a mirage so
it might seem like the popular opinion
on cryptocurrencies might be a little
mixed however let's have a look at what
the other great minds in the world have
to say about it transforming the
underlying economics and financial
services through digital currency will
help those who live in poverty directly
it will also support a host of other
development activities including health
and agriculture and for the first time
at least in my experience and my
knowledge freedom true financial freedom
is possible with crypto currencies if we
have the common sense to use them
appropriately paper money is going away
yes and crypto is a far better way to
transfer value than pieces of paper so
back to the Internet I believe that it
or not will have a native currency
really they'll have a native currency
and I don't know if it's Bitcoin it I
think it will because just given all the
tests it's been through
and the principles behind it how it was
created and you know it was something
that was born on the internet that was
developed on the internet but it was
tested on you know it is of the Internet
so lots of Stoffer cryptocurrencies in
the future one of the most important
issues that cryptocurrencies need to
address is that of regulation
cryptocurrencies are often the preferred
currency for a bunch of illegal
activities like money laundering
smuggling narcotics and so on
thank suits decentralized nature and
anonymity regulatory and government
agencies would aim to bring virtual
currencies under regulation to ensure
they are and misused cryptocurrencies
will also gain widespread adoption among
merchants although currently they are
being adopted they still are in the
minority they would see more acceptance
among consumers the biggest challenge
that needs to be overcome is that
leptons users have towards
cryptocurrency due to the relative
complexity compared to the formal forms
of conventional currency other problems
that would be solved and how a computer
crash could virtually destroy all of a
person's digital fortune or how hackers
could steal from a virtual world these
issues will be combated by technological
advancements although the nature of
cryptocurrencies can be very volatile
and near constantly changing 2020 really
does look like it will bring
cryptocurrencies to the general public
and widespread adoption on that note
we've come to the end of this video if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
like share and subscribe to our channel
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simpler
[Music]